are you a geek
i'm a geek and i'm not afraid to admit
it and just because the fact that i am a
geek i found a great website for you
guys your geeky followers so you might
not be indeed but you might be
interested in this kind of stuff just
because i am a geek
the man's name is chris pirillo and you
really need to go check out his youtube
channel it'll be in the description box
wherever it is i pointed at it at one
point
and um
so yeah he does all sorts of great
videos i subscribed to him just a couple
years ago but not years ago a couple of
months ago he does a lot of great
youtube videos on software on hardware
on issues on tech on the newest uh the
newest software operating systems that
come out he goes over the internet he
goes over new websites cool websites
that i use i use tons of websites every
time i watch one of his videos i'll
learn something new and this guy i also
have to tell you has a really sweet
website that i want to show you guys
called geeks.corillo.com
and i'll just give you a little preview
of all the stuff you can do on his
awesome website especially for geeks
all right now we're on my desktop here
and i'm just going to pull it up in
safari and here it is it's
www but it's geeks.perillo.com
this in his website i've originally
signed in i wrote in my name and
everything and it says here's a few
things you can do right now you can
invite friends you can have geek friends
trust me there's a lot of members and a
lot of geeky friends you can upload
photos maybe have your new computer set
up have people comment on it at a video
upload some of my own youtube videos to
here just to give people a good idea of
what i'm about at applications because
there's a lot of cool stuff we can do on
the site as well as widgets etc and you
can also edit your own profile and
people can send you messages there are
forums for you to check out cool stuff
create posts and maybe he'll feature
your posts in one of his uh videos or
emails and stuff really really cool so
um if i go to my profile obviously i
made my profile about
a month ago so it's not the most
advanced profile in the world but pardon
my extremely slow internet speed today
i'm uploading a video right now but um
see here's a couple things what is um
what is here's my latest activity so i
replied on the discussion what is your
windows experience index rate you i i
showed 5.9 my youtube claims so you know
i went over all this stuff um
this is all these things i've been doing
my last login you know cool stuff about
me
because i'm so geeky and then your geek
activity this is just a great website if
i were to create a post right now i
would get an email every time um every
time i wanted someone to respond to it
every time someone responds i get an
email so um really guys check this
website out check out geeks.parrilla.com
sign up subscribe subscribe to his
youtube channel check out his website
locker gnome he's really really cool
so if you are a geek and you want to
associate yourself with other geeks this
is the place for you and me so uh thanks
for watching this one and um come back
subscribe favorite peace
you